[MUSIC PLAYING]
SEBASTIAN SCHEITER: So
first of all, thank you.
Thank you for joining.
I know this is a late
session, and in some cases
I am between you and happy hour,
or a drink, or a restaurant.
So I really appreciate it.
We'll try to make this as
informative and as helpful
as possible.
Really great to see
some familiar faces.
There some customers
out there and so,
great everyone for attending.
We're going to try to do
two things here today.
We're going to set
a general baseline
on what Chrome is, where
Chrome OS came from,
how the Chromebook came to be,
where we're going with Chrome.
And David, one of our lead PMs
is going to help us do that.
And then we're going to switch
the narrative a little bit
and look at Chrome, really, from
an operating system perspective
and walk a little bit through
how customers are using Chrome
OS today to solve very,
very real problem,
specifically in manufacturing
and specifically in retail.
So without further ado,
David, take it away.
DAVID KARAM: Thank
you very much.
So I'm David.
I'm a product manager
on the Chrome team.
And it is really
my mission to make
this device a beautiful
device for the enterprise.
And what I want to
do today is tell you
a little bit of
the brief history,
just so you know
where Chrome OS came
from because I think a
lot of these sweet sauce
or the secret sauce of Chrome
OS comes back from the Genesis.
We will talk a little bit
about that, back in 2010,
what were the
founding principles
and how far we've
come since then.
So, talk a little bit
about the milestones
we've had along the road.
And from then, talk
a little bit more,
why is this a great
device for the enterprise
and all of the different
value propositions
it's bringing to the table.
So starting off with a brief
history, this is the CR48.
This was actually the
very first Chromebook.
That was back in 2010.
And Chrome browser has
been picking up all
across the world, right?
A lot of workloads were
moving to the web and people
within Google thought,
what if we could actually
make a computer that is built
for this world where everything
is in the Cloud?
What if your
computer didn't suck?
It didn't take
minutes to boot up.
It could boot up in seconds.
What if all your apps
and all your data
were actually delivered from the
Cloud, and stored in the Cloud,
so that you can
secure them remotely
and you can deliver
them remotely?
And what happened was,
a bunch of engineers
actually got together and
hacked what you see here.
It was a Chrome
browser in full screen.
They removed a lot of the bloat
in existing operating systems,
things that we check, for
example, for the floppy disk,
so move that away.
And then have a very,
very slimmed down run
time, which ran only
the Chrome browser.
And what they had was
this Chrome browser
running in full
screen and a keyboard,
and that was basically a book
with Chrome and Chromebook.
So this was the Genesis.
And since then, a lot of meat
has been added to the OS,
right?
There's been a more elaborate
runtime system for apps,
there's been a launcher shelf--
everything you tend to relate to
a traditional operating system
environment.
But throughout all
this and since then,
we've actually never let go of
the founding principles which
were speed,
simplicity, security.
So even seven days down,
seven years down the road,
this thing still boots
up in five seconds even
with the [INAUDIBLE]
system, which
we're going to talk about
later with the Play Store.
We still boot up
in five seconds.
So this is the joke now,
that Chrome OS is actually
the fastest booting
Android phone.
And that is very true.
Five seconds you're in, you can
actually use your Android apps.
So we've never really
sacrificed on this.
Simplicity is, again,
one of these things--
both user-facing simplicity
and admin-facing simplicity.
It should be very easy to use.
There's no clutter
on the desktop.
Your apps are there.
Your data is there.
It's all very clear to you.
And even from an
admin's perspective,
it's very, very easy to
scale for tens of thousands
of devices in a fleet with very
little management overhead.
And finally,
security, and this has
been really the
cornerstone of Chrome OS
because we've built it--
always every single
feature we've
added, from the very basic
boot sequence of the OS,
all the way up to the apps
that are on the system,
they've been built
with security in mind.
And we're going to talk
a lot more about that
during this talk.
So what happened since then?
Since then, and if we fast
forward now to Q2 2016,
we actually became
the number one device.
Back in 2016, we actually
became the number one device
in education.
And the schools actually
loved that value proposition
of speed, security,
simplicity, but even went
beyond that for them.
Sheer ability was a big thing
because if you look at schools
and how they deploy Chromebooks,
they just bring them in a cart
into a class.
And then, students just
pick up a Chromebook,
any Chromebook, from
the cart, log in,
and they have everything
they need there.
And we're going to
talk more about that.
And Seb is going to talk about
how even enterprise customers
are using such models in
deployment, what is actually
a very, very interesting thing.
Another thing that
they latched onto
was management
and manageability.
Because schools
traditionally have had,
they're not extremely
tech savvy and they
have very little IT resources.
So now, I'm a district and
I have 100,000 students.
How do I actually deploy
Chromebooks across the 100,000?
And today, we have
examples in the field where
you have tens of
thousands of Chromebooks
with maybe two or three
IT admins supporting them
full-time.
And this is something
that, really,
you cannot do except
with a Chrome device,
out of all the options
you have on the market.
And riding on all that momentum,
what happened in Q2 2016
was, IDC came out with
this report and said,
actually Chromebooks have
been outselling Macs in the US
for the first time
since their inception.
And this was a very
important milestone for us
because, at this point, we
felt really, really good.
And we knew we were going
in the right direction
because, not only did we
think this was a good idea,
but, actually, the market
was voting for this.
And people were voting
with their money.
And for us, this is really
very, very important signal.
And we don't take this lightly.
We're actually
very happy with it
and you just, we're
going to keep innovating.
We're going to keep driving
things in this direction.
And a lot of the stuff we're
going to tell you about today,
also, in terms of what to look
out for with this product,
we tend to keep this trend
going forward and moving
and taking more and more
market share in the laptop
and the convertible segment.
And we didn't stop at EDU.
Because this was
great and it was
great to have this very nice
use case with education,
but we actually focused
more on enterprise.
Because what happened was,
all these value propositions
actually ring very true for
the enterprise as well--
speed, simplicity, security
is a big thing, right?
Shareability, manageability,
they're all things
that enterprises really want.
And what happened was, even
without any strong push
from us, small and
medium-sized businesses
were pulling Chromebooks
off the shelf,
just like regular
consumers were doing,
and then were using
them in the workplace.
And what we wanted
to do, we went
and talked to these customers
and figured, why do you
actually like your Chromebook?
And our intuition was
correct, that they actually--
all these things
that we care about
and we're developing
in the product,
they loved and they
were buying into it.
And we asked them,
what more do you need?
And we got a big laundry list.
And then, we of course, had
over work cut out for us.
And we've been spending the
last two or three years building
for the enterprise.
And the results
have been amazing
because, for one, this number
you've seen here on this,
we're selling almost
a million laptops
into the market every year now.
And this is a very, very
major milestone for us
because, again, it proves
that we are on the right trend
there.
And we're going to keep
going in this direction.
The other one is,
we've also signed up
a lot of big, big companies.
And this has been
our transition,
from just supporting this
very small and medium-sized
businesses were
already on G Suite,
and going to these
more larger companies.
So we wanted to make sure that,
even in very complex computing
environments, if you
think of enterprises--
about their networking needs,
about their virtualization
needs, about their
security needs--
it's not easy to come
with an option that
satisfies all the, that
checks all the boxes
for these enterprises.
So, after a lot of
hard work, and we've
been able to sign up
a lot of major deals,
and we've seen
Chromebooks become
more and more of a
viable alternative
for these big companies
and in very, very
complex environments.
And of course, this
is-- we're going to keep
investing in this field.
We're going to make sure that
whenever you take a Chromebook,
even if you have a very complex
set-up in terms of networking,
in terms of identity,
in terms of apps,
that Chromebooks
can actually compete
with any other device that can
be out there on the market.
So what I want to do now--
and this is, give you
a bit of the genesis of
this, where it started
and how we took those
founding principles
and built this operating
system around it
and all the major milestones
we've passed through.
What I want to do is deep
dive a little bit, right?
How did we take this device--
that was just the browser
and was built for the Cloud--
and how do we make it, now,
a mature operating system that
keeps building for the Cloud?
So we start from a very
basic level, right,
even on the operating
system level.
What you should
know about Chrome OS
is that, actually,
we provide the images
and we deliver the images
for the operating systems.
And it's very different from
traditional operating systems,
take example, Windows laptops,
you need your IT admins
to have images that then
they take on a stick
and then they put and
they burn on the hardware.
That is not true of Chrome OS.
Chrome OS, Google manufactures
all the images, of course,
in partnership with OEMs.
But then, we deliver
them off of our Cloud.
And this makes a very,
very big difference
because now we know which
versions of the operating
systems are out there.
And we can push things
like management, like apps
onto those operating
systems and we
can make sure that all the
systems are up-to-date.
And this is very, very important
because it has very strong
security implications.
We know that if any
vulnerability comes in a Chrome
device we can actually patch
it and update all the devices
in the field within
24 to 48 hours.
And this goes back
to the fact that we
know of all these images
and we provided these images
in the first place.
So here, the Cloud perspective,
even on this very low level,
which is for the
operating system,
plays in and allows us to
deliver an experience first
of all, that is uniform
across all devices
and that is very, very secure.
Now, we take this a step further
because the reason admins say,
for example, have to
burn images onto hardware
is because they want to provide
a certain experience, right?
And what you want to do is,
not just deliver the image,
but deliver all the capabilities
on top of that image.
So now we have the management
layer for Chrome OS.
And this is where you start
customizing the experience
for both your users
and your devices.
So we support north of up to
100 policies on the device,
and these deal with anything
from user management,
device management,
app management,
and network management.
So now you get this device--
true, you can not
burn the image,
but then you can go to a web
console, click a few buttons,
and all those images
just transform
and they become tailored
to your use cases,
to your users use cases.
And if we take a look a bit
deeper into each one of these,
for example user
management, you can
define which URL's
in the browser
the user is actually allowed
to go to and which are not.
You can find which printers
a certain user can use.
And this is very
important because now, you
can actually tailor
the experience
for that particular user.
And these policies,
because they're
delivered from the
Cloud, they can actually
follow the user
anywhere they go.
So the user picks up
another device, even
their personal device,
and they log in,
these policies follow
the user around.
So now, it's very,
very interesting
because you have the same
management instance regardless
of which device
the user is using.
And this will come to
mean many things, right?
It means now you can have a cart
model where you just bring cart
in and users can pick up
any device they want, mainly
because, as soon as they
sign in all the policies
that need to apply to them will
apply and the experience they
need to have will
be on that device.
If you look at device management
you can set things like sign-in
restrictions, who can and
cannot sign-in into the device.
So that allows you to
actually secure your devices.
You can set things
like [INAUDIBLE]
and even configure these
devices to be public sessions
or kiosks.
Now, this is very,
very interesting
because now you can use your
devices in different ways.
Suppose it has been with
user first for one year,
but then you want to
repurpose for something else.
You actually don't have
to touch the device,
you just send it somewhere.
Click a few buttons on the
Cloud and then the device
is automatically repurposed.
So now it was something the
user was using every day
to do their work, but now it's
a kiosk session in your lobby
where users can come in and
do work across the device.
Now, we look at app management.
And this is also
important because you
don't want to just
manage the devices,
you also want to deliver apps on
which users can do their work.
And this happens also from
the Cloud because you have--
all apps that can be
delivered to the Chrome device
can only be delivered
from the Play Store
or from the Chrome Web Store.
And again, you go
to the console,
you click a few buttons, and the
users have the apps they need.
And the same
applies for networks
as well, VPNs, certificate
provisioning, flows,
all of that can just be
pushed from the Cloud
and tailor made for
the particular users
without ever having to
touch the device itself.
Now, a little bit of note
on app delivery, and this
is actually quite interesting
because since all the apps that
can come to the device
can come from the Cloud,
there are many things that
become possible, right?
These app policies are
actually user policies.
So again, a user can just
sign-in into any device
and those apps are delivered
within that user session.
So that makes it
very, very interesting
and would not be possible
otherwise with, say,
for example, if you have
executables on a stick, which
are distributing.
So there is a lot of benefit
for all these workflows actually
coming from the Cloud
because you can control them
easily and remotely and
this allows you to scale,
as you mentioned, for example,
with schools with 100,000 users
with three or four IT admins.
So it becomes a huge
benefit with scale
and you don't have to maintain
servers to deliver apps,
you don't have to maintain
servers to deliver files
and operating system updates.
And now, once everything is
in place for your users--
of course your users
on those devices
are going to be doing all sorts
of stuff and generating data.
They might be
making modifications
to the operating system,
adding bookmarks, pinning items
to the shelf.
And we have many technologies,
Chrome sync, Android backup
and restore, Google Drive, all
these technologies actually
allow you to save all
that state that users
generate in the Cloud.
And this is very, very
interesting because the moment
that your users go somewhere
else on another device
that state comes
back to them, right?
And so you don't have
to worry that something
got lost because a device
got broken or lost.
The user can just move to
another device, any device,
and all that stuff would
actually follow them around.
And, last but not
least, I just want
to tie this in with
security because its such
a core principle
for us, and show you
that for us, security is not
just client-side security.
Our goal, of course, is
client-side security,
but we actually leverage
the Cloud a lot with that.
One example of that
is delivery of apps.
If you look at the Play Store
and the Chrome Web Store,
we actually have automated
systems in the Cloud
to do malware detection.
This means you don't need to do
malware detection on the client
because the combination
of server malware
detection and
management on the client
allows you to install only
a very specific set of apps
and nothing else.
And you offload that task
of checking for malware
and scanning malware
to Google because we
have very elaborate
systems on our backend.
And the moment
malware is actually
detected we have the ability
to remove all, you, and even
Google, has the ability
to remove that very, very
malicious app if it's
detected from any system
out there in the world.
Another one is, as I
mentioned, OS and app updates,
which happens automatically
from Google servers.
And this is very
important because you
don't need an admin in between
to actually take that patch
and apply it to the devices.
And first of all, it removes
the burden from the admin,
but second of all, it also
removes the margin of error.
You can't forget a patch
or you can't have a system
out there in the field that
is just not being updated.
The third one is management and,
as you mentioned, because this
is coming from the
Cloud we can actually
make sure that it
follows the user around.
And this is what we mean by
cross-device policy compliance,
you can make sure that
your users on any device
are compliant.
And this has very strong
security implications
because if you have certain
policies in place meant
to secure the endpoint, you can
be sure that these policies are
following the user around.
And, last but not
least, I actually
want to tell you about one
new technology we developed,
which is verified access.
And this is, again,
uses a combination
of client and server.
And this allows you to
cryptographically guarantee
the integrity of your endpoints.
So we know that Chrome OS
always goes in very fine boot
and you can guarantee
that the code that
is running on the
system has been
verified to be signed by
Google and deployed by Google.
So we have a good sense
whether malware actually
exists on the device.
But then again, on your servers
where you have sensitive data--
so for example,
on the server that
provides a certificate for the
user to access the network,
or the server that
provides email--
you can actually
come back and ask,
is this a Chrome device
and verified boot
and is this a Chrome device that
has enterprise policy applied
to it?
And Google servers can
answer you with a yes or no.
And the very
interesting thing is
that this yes or no is a
cryptographically-sealed
promise from Google
because it's hardware bound
and it's leverage uses the TPM.
And it's very different from
everything else on the market
where these checks are much
more based on heuristics.
So if you take the
same kind of software
that does integrity
checks on other platforms,
it will check, for
example, is there
a lock screen, is
there an anti-virus
running on the device, right?
So you get these checks they
are actually hardware bound
and this is very, very
unique in the laptop market.
And again, it's a combination
of delivering things
from the Cloud, you
enroll with the Cloud,
but then your device boots
up and does verified boot.
And then you can combine
the two to deliver
a very, very secure
implementation, which
is along the lines of everything
I've mentioned on the slide.
So now that you have a very
good sense of how we leverage
the Cloud to actually do all
these things on a Chrome device
and all the benefits
from that, let's
talk a little bit
about how we actually
think about Chrome
devices and where
we think the sweet spot is.
And for us, the
sweet spot really
is on this intersection of
mobility and productivity.
And as we look at the market, we
see devices like, for example,
the Windows Surface
or the iPad Pro,
and you look at them--
with the Surface is
a great device for productivity
because it runs the Windows OS,
it has the range
of Windows apps,
but then again, if you flip
it around it becomes a tablet.
It's not really, doesn't really
have that mobile sense to it,
right?
The apps are not
optimized for touch,
they're not really working
well in tablet mode.
The iPad is kind of
the complete opposite
because it has all these
apps that work really
well in the mobile sense.
But then again, it doesn't
have multi-windows,
it doesn't have the
things that actually you
would need for a
productivity-based device.
And what I'm going
to try and show
you right now is where we
combine both with Chrome device
so that it really becomes a
strong contender in that space.
So when you talk
about mobility--
and this was the
big announcement
we made almost a year now
ago in June in IO last year,
which was support for
Google Play on Chrome OS.
And this was very,
very important
because it solved some very
basic problems with the Chrome
devices, right?
Number one, it was
the app gap, right?
So Chrome was a
beautiful device.
We all loved it and it had all
the things we mentioned before,
but then you didn't
have the breadth
and the depth of apps of
the [INAUDIBLE] system
that you needed.
And you didn't
have the developers
engaged in providing
and bringing their apps
onto the Chrome platform.
And Google Play solves
a lot of that, right?
Because we have a very good
story of compatibility.
So any app that actually
runs on your Android phone
is capable of running
on the Chrome device
without any modifications.
So now, we actually
get all these apps
that were built for Google
Play onto the Chrome device.
And this is very
important for us
because every single software
vendor, enterprise or consumer
vendor, is actually on
the Android platform.
And this allows us to bring
these all this capability
into Chrome OS, which makes it
a much, much, much better device
fit for, not just for mobility,
but overall enterprise
and consumer viability.
The second one
was offline, being
a device that's relied
very heavily on the browser
and on the web meant you always
needed an internet connection.
Now granted, the web
is making strides
towards providing offline
capability with things
like service workers and,
even if you look at G Suite
it has very, very good
offline capability,
but those tend to
be the exception.
Most apps on the web are
written with online in mind
and some of them
support offline.
And, on the Play
Store you actually
have the complete opposite.
You have apps that were written
with a very strong sense
of offline because most of the
time your phone is actually not
connected to the internet.
So now, we have
this huge breadth
of apps that actually work well
really, really well offline.
And once they connect
back online of course,
they sink their data
back to the Cloud.
So again, using things like
Android backup of the story,
even the apps, within
the logic themselves,
you have data backup, right?
You have the offline capability
but without the downsides
of offline, which
is what happens
when the device
gets lost or what
happens when it gets stolen.
The third one is
native capability
and this was something
we found lacking
in Chrome OS for a long time.
We didn't have a very
rich set of APIs.
So if you were a developer, say
if you were Citrix or VM or one
of these developers, where
you need a very elaborate API
surface to actually
provide a rich experience,
you didn't have
that on Chrome OS.
But if you look
at Play developers
and what they have, in terms
of developing Android apps,
they have a very,
very rich set of APIs.
And they can use that
now to actually bring
these experiences
to Chrome devices.
And this brings me
to my last point,
which was developers story.
And now, developers have
a very, very decent story
in terms of bringing
apps onto the platform.
Right?
Develop an Android app,
right, if it actually
needs a very rich
set of APIs, needs
to do hardware interaction, it
needs hardware acceleration,
it needs a touchscreen,
all these things, now you
have a very clear path
towards bringing your app over
onto the Chrome platform.
And of course, this
was all software.
So what we really need
here is the form factor
to match that, because
bringing in the Play Store,
we also want the form
factor that brings
the best out of the Play Store.
And these were
two of the devices
we've launched
recently, which was
one with Samsung and with Acer.
And these devices
actually become tablets
and they have a stylus.
So it's actually
very, very interesting
overlap between everything
the Play Store gives you.
So now, you can
use it as a tablet,
but then also flips
into a laptop--
so for all your
productivity needs as well.
And the stylus of course brings
another one of those mobile
feels to it.
And we're working with
different software vendors
and actually getting the
best out of this form factor.
So in looking forward,
we are actually
working with a lot of
these app developers.
So, it will be companies like
Citrix, VMware, Mirosoft,
Adobe, and even
within Google itself,
we're working with a lot of our
first party apps, developers,
things like Hangouts,
G-mail, G Suite,
to actually bring the
best of these apps
onto the Chrome devices.
And moving into 2017,
and also into 2018,
expect to see a lot of
that, a lot more devices
like the ones I just
showed, which bring out
the best of the Play Store, but
also a lot more partnerships
with app developers to bring
more desktop great capabilities
to these apps and make
them work really, really
well on a Chrome device.
So now that we've
looked of mobility,
let's take a little
bit at productivity
as well because this is
not just a device that
can help you do your
mobile work or help you
when you're on the
run, it should also
help you when you're
on your desk, when
you want to connect
to a multi-monitor
and actually do work for say,
two or three hours in a row.
So how does Chrome
OS fair there?
We think it actually
does pretty well.
It's a very highly
performant OS and there's
a lot of performance
you can get out
of a Chrome device for
much less hardware.
And I think some people mistake
this sometimes or see it
from a wrong angle because
they think, oh well, you know,
Chromebooks are
low-end hardware.
Well, there's a
different spin to it
and it is the fact that to get
the same kind of performance
you get say, from
a $1,000 laptop,
you actually only need to
throw $600 worth of hardware
at the Chrome operating system.
And this was because
the operating system
itself is very light and has
been built to be very light.
And this doesn't
change, even as we bring
the Android system onboard.
Because if you think
about the Android apps,
and apps from the Play
Store, they've actually all
been built to run on very
low-end hardware, phones,
ARM chips, very little memory.
So now, you take those
apps and you put them
on a laptop, which
has an Intel processor
and these apps are
really, really snappy.
So all these things combined,
the lightness of the OS
and the fact that all the
apps were built anyway
for low-end hardware, means you
can throw much less hardware
to get the same experience.
So now, if you want to
do a premium Chromebook,
we would not need to throw
more than $1,000 of hardware
on it to match
what you would need
to buy for $2000 from
a different vendor.
And moving onto
that, we also make
sure that the experience
within the operating system
supports these
productive use cases.
So, not only have we brought all
the apps from the Play Store,
but we make sure the
integration of these apps
actually works really well.
So we look at things
like multi-sized windows.
You can actually
resize your windows,
things you're actually used
to doing on a laptop device,
but they weren't really part
of how Android was built--
look at things
like multitasking,
multi-profiles,
integration with keyboard,
integration with multi-monitors.
So all these things
we try really
hard to make them work
really well because we do
want this to be perceived
as a highly performant OS,
as an OS that really works
for enterprise workloads.
Now, the second part
of this, and this
is where it really excels, is
we have desktop-grade enterprise
browser as well.
If you look at Chrome
browser across all platforms,
but especially on Chrome
OS, it is actually
a very, very powerful browser.
So even now when we
have the Play Store,
we actually don't bring
the Chrome browser
from the Play Store.
We use the same Chrome browser
we have on Linux and on Mac
because we do want you to have
this desktop-grade experience--
pushing extensions that have
to do with productivity.
And it is fully manageable,
as is all of the other OS.
So everything we
said about management
applies to the Chrome
browser as well.
And it's very, very
highly performant,
even under massive workloads.
So depending how much hardware
you have in your hand,
you can open up 20,40, 50 tabs.
The thing will actually be able
to run really well with them.
And just to make
sure we know as well
that, this is not just for
when you have a laptop in hand
because what we are doing now,
and based on the form factors
we're coming up with,
which can become tablets,
we are making sure that
the Chrome browser, even
the desktop version of it, works
well and is touch-optimized
and it's working
offline capable.
So we're bringing the
newest versions of Chrome
that have technologies
like service workers,
but we also optimizing a UI
so that it's touch-enabled
so that when you do flip
into a tablet form factor,
or using the touchscreen,
Chrome browser, even
in it's desktop version, is
working really, really well.
And one last point
here is that as we
drove these enterprise
integrations and we
brought better support for
enterprise use cases, what
we've seen--
and this is a big
part of the work we've
done over the last few years--
is that integrations across
the board for everything
that enterprises
need, so everything
ranging from identity,
networking, certificates,
storage, and virtualization,
all these things
we're actually not fully
possible on a Chrome device
if you look three years ago.
If you look at
identity, for example,
the only way to
log-in to a Chromebook
was through a Google account.
Now, you can actually log-in
with your Active Directory
account, Ping, Okta, Clever, so
whatever your identity provider
is, as long as it's
Salmon compliant,
it can actually allow you to
log-in to the Chrome device
with it.
If you look at
storage, the only way
to do storage, like Cloud
Storage on current devices,
in the beginning was
through Google Drive.
But now, we've added support for
third party storage providers
so now, if you're a Box
or Dropbox customer,
or even you have your own
network fileshare on Pram,
you can connect the
Chrome device to that.
And for all legacy app
needs, whether you're
doing full desktop
virtualization or just app
virtualization-- working
very, very closely
with vendors like
Citrix, VM, or Amazon
WorkSpaces-- to bring the best
of virtualization to the Chrome
device as well so that
even as you migrate away
from the Windows
environment into the web
and into Android workloads,
you can still get access
to the old apps that you still
need to run for your users.
And just to also mention, that
we mentioned form factors are
convertibles as well,
but that doesn't mean
we're not actually
working really hard
to also produce
really great laptops.
And this is where I put this in
more of the productivity sense.
These do have, many
of these laptops
actually have touch
screens, but they
are made to be more like
fully-formed laptops.
And we are working
with these vendors,
with OEMs like HP,
like Lenovo, to bring,
for example-- this is Lenovo's
ThinkPad-- to actually
bring those devices
onto the market
because we do believe that there
is a very big market for this.
And we want to have more
and more high-end specs.
Because for EDU we
had a lot of success
in the lower end of
the hardware spectrum,
but we realized enterprises
have much, much bigger needs
hardware-wise.
So we are working
with these vendors,
actually bring all
that onto the platform.
So with this, I'm going
to hand over back to Seb
because, to give
you a break from me,
but also because he
wants to tell you
about how all these things,
we're actually seeing them
in the field and how customers
are using all those value
propositions from
the Chrome devices
to make very, very
large deployments.
Thank you.
SEBASTIAN SCHEITER: So I
really don't have too much more
to add to David's
points, but there
are a couple of things I
do want to highlight when
we look at this and
how this actually
translates into the field.
And I'll hopefully
share some sound bites
from customers like
yourself who are actually
using this beyond the
Chromebook form factor.
I want to pivot the narrative
just a little bit away
from Chromebook or any
specific Chrome OS form factor
and really want to focus
on Chrome as the underlying
system for virtually
any of your screens
in the enterprise, whether it be
the knowledge worker, the power
user, whether it be
for signs, and thus
contextual information, whether
it's basically Chrome powering
a kiosk, or for that matter,
video conferencing technology.
The reality is that
one common theme
that we hear from CIOs in
the field in IT leadership
is that they consider Chrome
as a future-proof platform that
allows them to deliver on their
two to three year roadmap.
So I just want to
pause there and I
want to just underline that.
That's really, really important.
So we're moving away from
this narrative of Chrome
being a hardware player
and we're really--
the message that
is resonating is
that Chrome is now a
full-fledged operating
system that can virtually
power all your screens, right?
So when we talk
to IT leadership,
rather than looking at this
as a very tactical hardware
replacement game, this is
becoming much, much, much
more strategic.
Now, in reality,
and we know this
because we've toured
a lot of companies,
every CIO has a mandate
to move into the Cloud,
whether it's
infrastructure, whether it's
a platform as a service, whether
it's software as a service,
whether it's fully
embracing GCP,
or whether it's to deploy
that one single app that
lives in the Cloud
that has to be deployed
to numerous endpoints that
are geographically dispersed.
We think, and this
is something, again,
that echoes in the
field, that Chrome
can play a really, really
important role to make
that smooth transition
into the Cloud.
And while we, frankly,
think about future-proofing,
we really want to make sure
that the customer and ourselves,
we really put these four
core pillars back into focus.
Because at the end of the day,
and I know this is repetitive,
these are the key attributes
that virtually any success
or any project that we're
going to be involved with
is going to be measured against,
speed, simplicity, security,
shareability.
And personally, I think we
can truly help with these four
attributes.
Anecdotally speed-- I was
told not to use the logo
and not to use the name.
So I'll try to be as cryptic
as possible here, but--
speed, we have a customer
in the Chicago area
that is essentially using Chrome
kiosks attached to a touch
screen where associates
on the retail floor
input customer data.
That data then gets sent to
the cashier and at that point,
hopefully, the sale
gets converted.
Right?
They came to us because of speed
because even a 10 second lag
in that transaction actually
impacts the bottom line.
An unscheduled and unplanned
reboot of that terminal
has detrimental
effects to their PNL.
When we look at
simplicity and we
preach the story
of, we're Chrome
and we want to power multiple
endpoints, multiple screens,
we've got to make sure
that the user that
is using each and every
one of those screens
has the same user experience
and has the same user interface
across all these screens.
Security, this is arguably
one of, I would say,
the loudest USPs that
we hear in the field
where people want
to talk to us, I
have a really cool story there.
We have a customer that
actually has a corporate policy
that when their
executives travel abroad
they're supposed to hand
in their primary device
and pick up a Chromebook for
the duration of their trip.
In that specific
case, we actually
boot into a virtual desktop.
God forbid, if that device
then gets lost or left
in a cab in Shanghai
or Berlin, it's a $200
write-off versus a pretty
substantial data leak.
And then shareability, if you
listen to what David said,
you can sense that this paradigm
of one user to one device
really no longer exists.
We ran some numbers
with our customers
and it turns out that
over the course of a day
the power worker, the power
user, uses five devices.
So we're starting to
see this 5 to 1 ratio.
And arguably, if that's the
case, that we need to make sure
that you take a
device, you log in
or you not log in via
certain kiosk sessions,
and it becomes a
seamless experience
when, at the end of the day
you pick up a different device
or you go home and continue
where you left off three
to four hours before that.
and that's really,
really important.
Now, if you take the device
management and layer them
on top of these four
core principles,
this becomes a very, very,
very powerful enterprise story.
Because yes, Chrome--
we all get this
and we all believe in
this-- but all of a sudden
you can take devices and
you can repurpose them
and you can allow
the shareability
by a centralized Cloud-based
Management Console.
We have customers that have
thousands of devices deployed
in the field that are catering
to 100 different use cases all
based on policies that one
IT admin in North America
is essentially administering.
And David has said this before,
whether it's a user setting,
whether it's a hardware
setting, whether it's
a certificate setting, all this
can essentially be manipulated,
pardon the strong word,
down to the device level
So let me put a little bit
of meat to the bone here.
Specifically in retail and
specifically in manufacturing,
we have seen Chrome
devices being used
to optimize employee workflows.
And one of my colleagues
on the strategy side and I,
we went and
interviewed customers
and we basically asked, what
is the problem statement
that we should be solving for?
And this is
essentially the output.
This idea that, , throughout the
course of the day you have one
device that caters to multiple
users, to multiple use cases.
Historically, if you look
at all these segments,
those would have been a fleet
of devices, but in this case,
the Chromebook starts in
the back of the office,
the user logs in based on
his or her user settings,
but throughout the
day, and again, this
is someone retail biased,
throughout the day that device
actually migrates to
the front of the store.
That device then becomes a
product look-up, a catalog.
It becomes a digital sign.
In some cases even, it becomes
something that can give you
contextual information.
In this very specific
example actually,
this device at some point gets
handed over to the customer
and it floats around the actual
brick and mortar real estate.
And at the end of the day, the
employee picks up the device
and puts it back
on the Chrome cart.
That's a pretty cool story
given that this is also
a $300 endpoint.
Historically, you would
have solved for that
with multiple $1,000 endpoints.
So I always like to call it the
conversion-on-the-fly scenario,
but if you think about it, this
is now really a departure from
the Chromebook and EDU story.
This is something where we're
actually impacting workflows
and we're trying to
create effectiveness
amongst the associates.
One really additional
example here, specifically
in the manufacturing
space and if you've
attended some of the previous
sessions you know this,
is what our good
friends at Sanmina
are doing actually
down the road.
Sanmina, large
manufacturing company,
part of the Fortune
500, they basically,
are using Chrome OS devices to
replace paper-based processes.
And they started on their
manufacturing floor creating,
and this looks somewhat
manual, but I can guarantee you
it's actually
pretty cool, they've
taken a large
touchscreen, they have
taken a Chrome box,
attached it to it,
and they're booting up multiple
kiosks in multiple apps
based on the user, based
on that user's credential.
For temp workers, those
people don't actually
have to log into
the application.
It just boots up
a public session,
what I would
consider, basically,
a managed guest mode.
Now, they have increased
these employees efficiencies,
but what's nice is they
came to us and said,
we believe in Chrome being
the underlying platform
for our future and we
need to start somewhere.
And this is essentially
where they started.
So they created the subset of
users, they deployed rapidly,
they had about 2000 of these
endpoints in the field right
now, and are now organically
growing into other use cases.
And as Rajin, our lead
PM, said earlier today,
they're now really focused
on the knowledge worker
and making that happen.
One caveat, I should say is,
they are G Suite customer
and I believe they're
a GCP customer as well.
So they are going in
all Google, but it's
great to see that obviously
devices and Chrome are
one of those
substantial endpoints
and workflows to make this
one Google story happen.
Now, one other
great example where
a company has started small
and the story and the adoption
has really grown rapidly
and grown organically,
is what our friends here at
Charles Schwab are doing.
And may the demo
gods be with me,
I'm going to try to play
this video for everyone.
And he's much more articulate
than I am so, here we go.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- There are multiple sides
of Schwab's business.
And one of those sides
is the advisor side
or the institutional side.
And obviously, we offer a lot of
products and a lot of services
to our institutional customers.
I'm responsible for making
sure that we deliver on behalf
of what our clients need.
As we were looking for
solutions, bringing about
a device to the
branches where again,
clients could very easily
open up an account,
we reached out to our
colleagues over at Google
and we asked them whether or
not Google's Chromebook was
something that would
be applicable to what
we were trying to solve.
That was on a Friday.
On Monday morning we had two
of their top engineers engaged
with my engineers here.
3 and 1/2 hours later,
I get a knock on my door
and I'll never forget
what they said to me,
they said, we've solved it.
Google offered a number of
services and capabilities
within their Chromebook
platform that
were incredibly attractive.
One of them was the ability to
remotely control the devices.
We could force them
onto a specific network,
our network, if they
fell off that network,
they would be unusable.
If someone stole them we had the
ability to remotely wipe them.
I would say one of the unique
features of the Chromebook
has to do with their
operating system.
The device isn't burdened
with a lot of legacy
or with a large OS.
Instead, the experience
is, you open the Chromebook
and 10 seconds
later you're online.
Because of the kiosk capability
that the Chromebook had
to offer, when
one of our clients
came in to open
up a SIP account,
it was start up a new session.
And as soon as I Chromebook
was closed, session gone,
everything gets erased.
The full roll out
and development
started with a number of
weeks of user engagement.
We would take the Chromebooks
out to specific branches,
test it out, and
then from there,
it was making sure
that the device
could stand up and do exactly
what we need it to do,
but do it at scale.
When you're working with a firm
that's got hundreds of branches
out there and you're going
to eventually deploy well
over 1,000 of these
devices, the ability
to control them from
a central location
is absolutely paramount.
Really, the Chromebook was
the one that met our needs.
They work at any
time, all the time.
[END PLAYBACK]
SEBASTIAN SCHEITER: If
some of you noticed,
that was still our old
logo, Google for Work,
but no one saw that.
So I was very closely
involved with the Schwab deal
and the Schwab use case.
And again, a great
example where they
had a very clearly
defined problem
statement, a very limited time
to get something converted.
And we got to work.
The reason I would
say it worked so well
is because, quite frankly, the
only ask that I would always
have engaging with clients is
giving the problem statement
and predefine the users
that we should work with
and we will solve it out.
And if it's not a
fit, it's not a fit,
but that's how I would start.
These are not my
words, but they're
from the Wall Street Journal--
this was this happened
late last year where,
again, after a pretty
strong showing last year
we really saw traction
and saw momentum,
saw credible momentum in
the enterprise and adoption
across a bunch of key verticals.
And so, I would
encourage you to try
to take that seriously
and look at Chrome really
as a formidable
player in that space.
When prospects and
customers ask me,
that's great, Seb, but
where do we go from here?
How do we even
tackle this thing?
Because we all know, either
from a client perspective
or even from a
manufacturing perspective,
tackling the OS space is 35
years of legacy architecture.
That's really, really scary.
So the piece of advice I would
have is, start small, deploy
quickly, and grow organically.
And what do I mean by that?
If you start small,
again, pre-defined users,
give us a problem statement
that we can solve.
So in the Sanmina
use case it was
basically replacing
paper-based processes,
doing something very, very
tangible within their supply
chain, within their workflow.
Deploy quickly.
I know we live in this
world of pilots and POCs,
and they're all real
and we shouldn't
forget about them, but in
reality, give the device
or give the solution to the
user and let them decide.
I'm a big fan of
just, basically,
ripping or replacing and
just seeing if it works
and if it doesn't work then
that's a valid feedback
and we'll move on.
So the deployment time
frame is something really,
really important.
Give it to the user, let
them decide whether it works.
And if we do our
job right, then I
do think that there
is this organic growth
pattern within the enterprise
across all your screens
that will make
Chrome successful.
And that's really, frankly,
what we're here to do,
and that's what my
team is there to do,
and that's what David's
team is here to do.
[MUSIC PLAYING]